Một lần mình đi không tá hả nước ngoài, cái hôm đây thì mình có nhằm cất tình nhắn của một đưa chai
để bạn nói là ngã em đoay, bởi vì em không biết hợp và nhìn điện cộng một em về quay ở cái là đình
nhưng mà em không về, bà bây giờ em đi làm thà, thế thì mình bà là thế thì
bây giờ em có thể giúp được gì sẽ em thì bạn đi ngò là em chỉ cần một xuất cơ,
thế thì mình mới liết hẹp với một nhìn điện,
mà thì thì các bạn ý để cùng có một cái vừa ăn cho bạn ý thì cũng một là xem là
cái tâm đi và em đã làm sao thì khi mình về thì mình bị đưa là một phòng
ở nó là thì mình rất là nhiều nhưng mà nó không có hiệu quả,
mà người quyết định là không giúp em ở đường đại miếng lời mừng sống,
thì kéo một chơi lộ sục xuất, trắng phải là tổ chức này,
thật lập là để cho những người như thế giáo,
lúc khi các em đi để em biết tổ chức, các em còn tự thách mình,
mình có thương em thì thật khóc, mình có quảm tâm em thì thật khóc,
chúng ta có lúc sự gặp em từ vẻ khi các em không ngoảnh ở đây không,
hay là tưởng ta đang giả phó,
ở lúc khi nhân viên không đẹp ở đây, chúng ta giúp được ở bô điều kiện,
chúng ta nắp ở vướng gái hậu cạnh, chúng ta chờ nội,
đúng không biết hãy khả, lúng thời đi hậu và chúng ta để hỏa lưa cho các nó hỏa mỗi được giúp người thế nào,
chúng ta đồ khi mắt một cái xa làm để là chúng ta giúp hỏa thóc các bạn chúng ta mỗi,
khi mà chúng ta quyền mất là hỏa cú cá, nhỉ có cái chách nó hỏa mỗi.